è da tutti ragazzi io sono play e oggi
siamo i premi di won stufa vj grow
fangguo resto gioca demerito trovati su
emily wars to play che è un videogioco
bello allora gazzoli allora gazzoli la
scorsa settimana quando giocava dei
minimo su play sono arrivato alla terza
ora che è difficile
glielo posso assicurare di varati a
tavola e da tutti ragazzi ebbene lui
deve solo video sono fa vigenti siano
simili mostri play che fa rima sono
riuscito a fare lo scorso episodio due
notti tosti minchioni quei due notti che
sono tantissime per un episodio e sono
quasi riuscito a finirlo il problema è
che ci sono sti bambini ma non che mi in
groppa non i quattro secondi che è
successo non lo voglio sapere 9 locali e
va beh cosa vuoi dalla vita mia questo
ragazzi il pagliaccio che quando mi vede
fare una cosa e devo stare fermo perché
sennò mi grossa e fin qua questa invece
la bambina che quando mi vede devo
guardarla perché se non salta sul divano
sta minkia nati debitorie grazie brava
hai chiuso la porta in questa ora qui
ragazzi devo combattere nei tre insieme
che è impossibile cioè non so come
faccio assurdo se riesco raga ma non
avete idea delle medaglie che esigo se
riescono veramente medaglia a fiumi
no perché è impossibile c'è veramente
impossibile non credo di poterci mai
riuscirci è bello che devo tenere le
luci accese perché se non sono accese
arriva la bambina una volta non si è più
fatta vedere che la zia facendo è acceso
solo la luce
però ti sto guardando sì molto bella
anzi guarda
la porta si è aperta la mamma ti
chiamate vedere sti da scasso per
cortesia grazie prima le signore tesoro
e vedi che capisce le buone maniere
grazie sono contento che apprezzi ti
vengo a trovare però no no no no no no
no non l'ha dentro no
là dentro se là dentro non ci vengo se
invece te ne stai buona ce l'ha dentro
se no mi avevi ecco sono del pupazzo lo
dovevi fare immediatamente io prego
iddio che gioca ma no no no no no no no
no visita sono cito santo dio non avrò
mai più stock uno in vita mia è
impossibile avere lezzi sorella tesoro è
un mostro fermo sul fermo sono fermo
conferma sto guardando l'inferno perché
non c'è niente però vabbè ma [ __ ]
sapevo cela l'ombra che lampeggiava l'ho
vista l'ho vista sto gioco va nettamente
anche a culo perché se vi fermate
davanti a un corridoio mentre sul
pagliaccio goethe ferma non posso fare
più niente perché c'è la bambina agli
stupri oltre alla bravura deve anche
avere un culo tanto perché sono riesce a
fare una mazza altro giro altra corsa
visto che mi sto divertendo vai così non
è divertente c'è scritto questo sulla
lavagna ragazzi non è divertente no non
è divertente
preferivo giocare a quando non si sta
sulla cucina deficiente varie lo dico
torna per un giusto e [ __ ] co si sa
non si sta sulla cucina non si gioca coi
coltelli non si butta la spazzatura ecco
una brava a tutta la spazzatura deciderà
la iscritto a tutta la roba di sopra
brava ziano non è divertente
[Musica]
sai così divertente un pugno nel culo
con le divertenti giuro che divertente
provare a furia di passarsi la vita io
questo livello devo fare non esiste devo
finirlo ciò ma è una questione tra me e
me vero zio perfette rame lo schermo blu
ho detto che tra me lo schermo blu che
cosa vuoi dalla mia vita posso andare no
perché visto prima vado vado invece vado
vado vado vado vado vado bene a 3 per i
contendenti
no no zio solo un sito sono uscito dove
sei quasi cura perfetto scendi che sono
uscito per cui va culo gli pupazzetto
l'iva cui non c'è verso va assolutamente
a culo te ne vai
non lo so invitiamo anche gesù cristo
ok che grazie sopravvissuto a due
insieme grazie provare i posti 6 va a
donarmi a rega tutto spento tutto spento
tutto spento quanto vi odio la famiglia
vi odio dov'è dove non la vedo
non sa però dove un ragazzo non lo vedo
ecco mi chiami sono pagati ma non avete
quando la vedi e bruttissimo perché ti
salta in bocca quando ha voglia proprio
perché spunta che ride procede madonna
madonna madonna
ciao
attenti
la roba quanta roba ragazzi quanta che è
successo mi ha cresciuto gioco come ma
cosa sa che posso muovermi questo
successo siamo alla quarta ora ragazzi è
mai vista non so cosa sia cioè sento
sento sauron in sottofondo si sente
sauro cosa faccio pregasse un timer che
però non ho capito che se è successo
[Musica]
perdonatemi ragazzi ma non ho capito
cosa dovrei fare perché non ha senso non
ho capito ma che è 73 è stata cosa si è
spento tutto a c è stato il black out
cosa devo fare
[Musica]
cioè fatemi capire
devo sfuggire alla fifa ok ragazzi ho
detto paio di robe su internet come si
dovrebbe fare
e c'è stati fa che in teoria gioca a
nascondino con me c'è io la devo trovare
nella nostra mischia parte che non vedo
un pene
io posso andare 18 comunque c'è scritto
che posso andare 18
praticamente st bambina si nasconde c'è
un timer di sotto vi devo trovarla
mentre il timer scade ma non è non sono
io a trovarlo a quanto pare lei che
trova mente cioè non so se avete capito
adesso dovrebbe andare così dovrei
riuscire a trovarla nel tempo limite
mi chiamo al telefono non è il momento
non nel momento del telefono devo
trovare la bambina ecco eccola quindi si
ok ripartito il timer ok è così che deve
andare perché prima non ha funzionato
raga io già miracolo trovata una volta
come faccio a trovarla un'altra volta
impossibile comunque devo trovarla non è
sempre nel punto di primavera eccola la
vedo e poi che cosa faccio dopo dopo che
la prendo lo pensa ma adesso in teoria
dovrebbe essere da un'altra parte c'è la
dovrei provare un'altra parte
il problema è che non la trovo quindi è
inutile a noi ci siamo allora in teoria
in teoria sì come devo far passare le
ore adesso aspetto che scenda il
conteggio a 0 e poi quando mancano due
secondi dalla fine la tocco perché
almeno così passa il tempo e cosa
facciamo in questi 53 secondi ragazzi
potremmo raccontarci della nostra vita
passata e vorrei basta parlare dei cazzi
nostri torniamo al gioco e devo devo
toccarti ecco perfetto in teoria devo
fare così ogni volta che la vedo perché
deve passare il tempo non scatta mai
l'ora dopo vi dicevo ragazzi quando
andavo a scuola che facciamo un blog
c'è un blog e allora tutti ragazzi
vedete che sono video sono fa vj e oggi
siamo in un nuovo logo verde a settimana
è stata vinta da erika che ha fatto
verso disegno grazie a erika stato molto
gentile ma news di oggi e che fa
veramente buio nelle case poco buio ci
sono dei bambini che potrebbero
ucciderli mentre tentate di passare da
una stanza all'altra
per il resto soleggiato per quanto
riguarda il file risponde fallì perché
ciò che i giochi horror perché mi piace
essere masochista carta già dei fatti
facciamo scherzoso di pacchi ecco ciò
dei cannoli siciliani
anzi no è un babà nello magno buono ti è
piaciuto il video al suo commento mi
piace bella ciao già a parte se
stronzate da
da blogger inutili dov'è la famiglia e
greco 54 para fan cuore dove da dove era
dove era non c'era più e spari velica
volte non c'è ma io scappo mi butto qua
sotto
su kakà dietro
stava andando in un posto nuovo che figo
minchia che culo mi è apparso subito
davanti l'ho già allora sentite non
facciamo la roba del aspettare perché
sono mica mercato
maroni cosa se stai pisciando sul
pattumiera zia fammi capire c'è più rega
non c'è più e va beh è un bagher a
garibaldi sicurissimo perché è
impossibile che non ci sia veramente
assurdo e non c'era che cosa dovevo fare
più di così
sono sotto senso
con pochi posti 6 mi capitava ragazzi e
ho cercato ovunque era non conviene
spiegare st parte perché l'ho capita ma
più o meno che un crollo viene episodio
spero che i video vi sia piaciuto fatemi
sapere come continuano ma chiaramente
non so più che cosa fare cosa sento
servizio è piaciuto è stato un momento è
un mi piace anche a pulsioni facebook
come la notizia 16 10 miliardi subito e
buonanotte che vi serve anche a me serve
vabbè dai ragazzi
[Musica]